now a new documentary film about the
jailed WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
is getting its German Premiere at a
human rights Festival here in Berlin
Ithaca follows assange's Father's Quest
to free his son as he battles U.S
demands for his extradition
supporters for Julian Assange Gather in
London to show solidarity
he has strong support from those who are
committed to press Freedom not least his
former lawyer now his wife that this is
an enormous Monumental Injustice of a
man who is being persecuted by the
authorities who are using the coercive
powers of of the state in order to try
to punish him for doing the right thing
the journalist editor and activist who
founded Wikileaks and who was behind
major leagues including U.S Army
intelligence during the Iraq war is now
at the center of a news story Ithaca a
documentary focusing on assange's Father
John Shipton's fight for his release is
receiving its German Premiere while
Assange is kept in a high security
prison in the UK awaiting extradition to
the U.S where he may yet stand trial for
Espionage the film has some high-profile
contributions and the intensity of a
very personal story we're here and this
has only come about because we have a
child in the ship and
[Music]
you want to get him out
the film explores family bonds and
issues of press Freedom against the
backdrop of assange's restricted
movement from Ecuador's London Embassy
in 2010 to his arrest and incarceration
in a UK jail in 2019
where he is now awaiting an uncertain
future
and I am joined Now by Julian assange's
Father John Shipton welcome to DW Mr
Shipton pleasure to be
um an uncertain future what what are
your fears for your son's future Mr
Shipton oh that uh you know he'll be
extradited to the United States and face
uh uh the rest of his life in the
maximum security jail or
oh die yeah that's her
in some that's it yeah can I ask you
when you last uh saw Julian uh in the
August uh where visited
um and uh I'll go over this week and say
hello
so from Berlin to London
um can you tell us about his his health
how is his state of mind right now well
buoyed by uh you know the reception that
we're getting in
Germany and in particular Berlin
um those are events that
reverberate uh into the jail so you're
by yourself 23 hours in the cell what
the support outside the jail is Health
giving and uplifting and so people write
Julian letters and occasionally we get a
profile for example the most vigorous
support in Europe comes from Germany so
that's very heartening as you can
imagine
Julian of course has a has a wife he has
two children how often does he get to
see his family uh usually it's twice a
week but during covert they refused
visits of course yeah and uh Julian I
think has covered at the moment as a
consequence there's no visits until uh
the tests show negative yeah does he
have a sense of hope
I I I gather so because I you know he's
still with us and
without hope we disappear off the Earth
very quickly yeah both you and Julian
are Australian citizens
um Australia's attorney general Mark
Dreyfuss says that Julian's case has
gone on for long enough
um and he says that he he is in what
he's calling private talks with the
Biden Administration are you hopeful now
of a positive outcome oh very much so
the Prime Minister of Australia Anthony
Albanese has said us enough's enough
um Mark Travis the Attorney General is
acting on the matter as is the minister
for foreign affairs Penny Wong so we
expect a solution particularly in taking
into account the the last election in
Australia I characterize as an Assange
election
um 88 of the population in the latest
poll uh will want Julian returned to
Australia they want one
they want their boy home yeah
as you mentioned Australia's new prime
minister Anthony Albanese he does appear
to be much more sympathetic to Julian's
situation than previous governments but
can I ask still are they doing enough I
mean what would you hope for them to do
in addition to what's happening already
uh well you know I would hope they ring
me up and say can you go to the airport
and pick up Julian that I mean that's my
practical hope
other than that
negotiations diplomatic negotiations are
always very private and
I'm not the sort of
character to be involved that's I was a
builder and so you know negotiating
between two pieces of Timber I can do
with skill however negotiating with the
United States Department of State is
beyond my calling
Mr Shipton Julian has many supporters as
you've said but he does also have
critics what do you say to his critics
who say that he's brought this on
himself by trying to avoid Justice back
when Swedish prosecutors wanted to
question him on on sexual assault
charges oh you know
Julian was uh in seven and a half years
in the embassy Professor Nils Mills a
book outline
he was the Union rapporteur on torture
outlined all of the circumstances that
Julian was placed in there's a
conspiracy or conspiring as a better
word between the United Kingdom Crown
Prosecuting service and the Swedish
Prosecuting authority to keep Julian in
the embassy I'll reiterate that they
conspired to keep Julian in the embassy
that's not my word that's documents
released under foi there had been in the
history of the Swedish case four
prosecutors nine years it was the
longest preliminary
investigation in Swedish history and
finally the Julian took the uh the
Swedish Prosecuting authority to court
and the van the federal court in Sweden
ordered the Swedish Prosecuting
authority to progress the case Mr
Shipton we will have to leave it there
but thank you so much DW